okay what and so what sort of debts do
you have then places like this reveal
the reality of Britain's cost of living
crisis a debt advice service in one of
Leeds poorest areas seeing soaring
levels of demand we're easily seeing
double
what in the amount of inquiries that we
were getting previously now we can't see
everyone where we have a certain
capacity those numbers include people
struggling to pay their debts people
lose the houses we do deal with clients
who have eviction hearings
um eviction orders and we'll assist
clients with that
we will always make sure that a client
is prioritizing that so the roof over
your head is is number one that has to
come first the nearby dewsbury it's a
similar story Adam Wilby began to rely
on this food bank when he was unemployed
you get people looking at you saying why
is he using the food bank what's he
doing with these more his money Etc and
stuff and it just makes me embarrassed
he works now but still sometimes has to
return Alma utilities council tax my
rent and it just leaves me sharp then
and stuff with whatever when I get left
I just use it on the shopping and for my
shopping and stuff so so I've got food
to last me and stuff like that I have to
rely on the food bank these growing
pressures highlighted in the latest ons
figures on the cost of living crisis
more than a third of people have been
finding it hard to afford rent and
mortgage repayments
and one in 20 have run out of food and
been unable to afford to buy more
but both these numbers are far higher
for ethnic minority groups who at higher
levels are struggling to afford housing
and three times as many unable to afford
food
to places like Berman Thompson Leeds
where that ethnic minority divide is
felt it's one of the most Multicultural
areas in the city but also one of the
poorest here like everywhere else in the
country people are feeling the pinch
local councilors here are seeing the
crisis devastate lives while affecting
them too I feel the impacts like
everybody else in in the in my
constituency as well as
um you know around perhaps maybe all
over the country so truly um as what my
colleague Lucas said the government does
need to do more
of the economic forecast Bleak those
challenges were only worsen in
communities like these shingi marike Sky
News Leeds